so on behalf of the program in ethics
politics and economics I'm delighted to
welcome you to the annual robert h
little it's lecture in ethics and social
policy but before i introduce our
speaker David Auerbach co-founder of
Sanergy I want to tell you a little bit
about Robert little whatz whose
generosity made this lecture possible he
was trained in law but then he came to
the Yale Divinity School to devote his
energy to thinking about appropriate
ethical underpinnings of social policy
tragically he was diagnosed with cancer
in 1989 while he was still a student and
upon hearing the news he established a
charitable trust to support
interdisciplinary research teaching
scholarships in ethics and social policy
this lecture series is the fruit of his
vision and his generous spirit we're
honored to have with us today his sister
Laurie little whatz who's traveled here
from Mexico where she's an established
international artist and I'm delighted
to introduce David Auerbach a graduate
of Yale College and the MIT Sloan School
of Business
David Auerbach has spent years working
in the area of global development
including with the igni offend in Mexico
with the Clinton Global Initiative as
Deputy Chair for poverty of Ely
alleviation and I also learned that he
taught in China with our own Dan
Mattingly maybe that was right after you
graduated from Yale College and so we
hope that David is gonna say something
about the arc of his life his personal
journey and advice he has for us to live
lives that contribute meaningfully to
the world so David thank you for coming
and
thank you all right good afternoon
everybody
thanks thank you so much for inviting me
back to the campus I have not been here
in a few years so it's really exciting
to be here and thank you to the little
bit's family for making this happen it's
it's a real honor so yeah so as I said
so hey I'm here to talk a little bit
about the work that I do in Kenya and
for the the students and the EPA me
major and about the University and just
sort of ideas that you might have or my
experiences and how it could maybe
inform as you think about your careers
things that you could do so let's just
get into this so a question like what
does the city of the future look like
I've always been fascinated by this
question I grew up in London my mother's
here by the way I'm sorry I should say I
grew up in London and lived in Boston in
New York and you know I've always I've
always walked around cities just loving
that like the getting lost
walking through parks through museums
the energy and excitement of the place
and and then I moved to China and after
I graduated I did the Yale China
Teaching Fellowship for two years and
moved to a city in central China called
cha cha where Yale has been sending
students since 1908 so over a hundred
years now and you know you felt that
same energy and that same excitement but
also felt like a very different
different type of city that was like
incredibly intensely populated really
built up and there was just constant
jostling not just not just like on the
subway but everywhere and it wasn't
really an easy place to live in peace
and these Chinese City the city is
entirely Changsha are very much like how
cities throughout the developing world
are like much more so than New York and
so this here is a photo of Nairobi where
I live now
and in the foreground you can see these
are slums where over two and a half
million people live of the four million
people who live in in Nairobi and they
live on about 5% of the land mass so
it's extremely built up and that Nairobi
is typical of cities everywhere these I
mean like some of the Nairobi is growing
at about 7% per year
hey and globally two billion people are
going to live in slums by 2030 about
from about a billion right now so these
areas are just getting more crowded and
more built-up and urbanisation brings a
lot of challenges for everything
education energy housing and the thing
that I've become most passionate about
is sanitation and it's a really big big
challenge there's four and a half
billion people over half the world live
in cities live in communities where the
waste is never treated people are
effectively still living in their waste
and this has a huge profound health
consequence over a million people die
every year due to sanitation related
disease and from an economic perspective
it's about 260 billion dollars are lost
globally this and what it means here in
Kenya where we work 17,000 children are
dying every year due to sanitation
related disease 270 million dollars lost
in economic productivity that's about
one to two percent of Kenya's GDP and 90
percent of the waste is never treated so
how did we get here and this is
something that my colleagues and I think
about all the time first of all we so
we've broken it really into like three
three big challenges one is that slum
residents are never treated like
customers they're just thought of either
marginalized people who don't need
services or or beneficiaries they're
just treated like they should be
grateful for whatever comes to them
second is is that the focus is on access
not the full value chain you'll see
plenty of photos of toilets being opened
or buildings being opened or schools
being opened or our health care clinics
but you don't think about then what
happens thereafter and in sanitation
that's a big deal because toilets get
built and then if the waste is still
there that's when people get sick and
third the way that we think about the
world is terms in terms of sewers and
sewers are and I'll get more into this
are expensive and impractical that's
sort of provocative in the world that I
live in but but it's but it is something
but it is something that III encourage
us all to think about a little bit as we
go on so let me expand a little bit on
those ideas so first so when residents
are not treated like customers this is
what happens sanitation options are
undignified dirty and dangerous this
here is a pit latrine it offers a little
bit of privacy people pay to use these
and then the waste just drops down you
can see sort of inside of that toilet
there where those girls are students at
schools and like it's not at all
something that anyone would want want to
use when focus of is on access the waste
is never treated and this is the
grossest slide but it gives you
something to think about and and and so
what you have here on on the left is a
guy they call him an ambulance and the
reason they call him an ambulance is oh
he collects waste from the from a pit
and and then and then he puts it in a
barrel and he goes through the streets
and it's an ambulance because everyone
gets out of the way as he comes down the
street or and then where does that waste
get taken or maybe gets taken you might
get taken by a truck but in Kenya we
have a situation where it's not well
regulated and so and it's expensive to
transport waste in the areas place to
actually legally dump the waste is about
20 kilometers so like 15 miles away from
where people where these trucks are and
as a result it just gets dumped wherever
they can find it and they don't get you
know and there's a very poor regulatory
code around that and then the third
reason is
what about sewers so some really
incredible work was done for the city of
Dakar Senegal she's in West Africa 2
million people and said they basically
worked out how much it would cost to put
in sewers and how much and then to run
them over 20 years and they said would
cost about $56 per person per year
in the u.s. it's probably somewhere
around 150 to 200 dollars just to give
you some some context of how expensive
this really is so in Nairobi last year
we spent $7 per person per year and
reached about 40 percent of the
population and just in late 2016 they
passed the most progressive sanitation
policy in all of really in all of Africa
and they're gonna get to $12 per person
per year in spending by 2030 so you can
see there's there's a pretty simple math
problem here that even by 2030 we're
gonna be in a situation where it's five
times short of what we need to be
spending so make sure that everyone
gains access so this is where my company
synergy has comes in we do an off-grid
sanitation service for cities non Seward
areas and we do this through a pretty
simple model we build toilets in the
informal settlements we franchise them
to community members who run them keep
them clean safe and open we provide
support services for those operators
which ranges from everything from
well-explained from government relations
to 200 waste collection service then we
do the main waste collection so that's
really what differentiates us and people
get really excited about that when you
and we offered as a service and then
finally we convert and distribute the
way so we convert the waste into
valuable end products organic fertilizer
and animal feed and in doing so we're
creating value from the waste at the end
of the value chain so it makes it more
affordable but also incentivizes that
ways to get there safely
so this is what it looks like this is
how we build the toilets this is it this
is the fresh life toilet we've had a
couple a couple of guys who Raheem and
Sammy are here
we're in Nairobi this past summer so
they got to see this they know it exists
and so this is it's a bright blue eye
catching facility it has a translucent
roof and it's supposed to be a very
different experience from the from the
get-go underneath the facility is a
cartridge system and so we we use
cartridges that are actually the the big
companies like Unilever and such use to
import chemicals into the country
there's a huge secondary market and
we've fitted the design so that it can
work with those cartridges these are
pretty much all over the world and makes
it first simple a simple design the next
thing we do is we franchise it in so
it's like actually we create like a
legal contract with community members so
that they have to keep the toilets clean
safe and open and we do that three
different ways one is that we have guys
who run them as small businesses and
this is actually how we started so it's
a commercial model so they'll charge
people to use the toilets and they make
an income office just how people already
did this in Kenya anyway and so and so
this is just a cleaner safer option more
convenient set but then we wanted to go
deeper into the communities and so what
we built over the last couple years in
particular is a residential model and so
we work with landlords who are providing
these to sanitation to their attendants
as a value add service and so landlords
they increase their rent by a dollar or
two so so to cover their cost and then
we just charge them on a leasing basis
so it's just sort of like Netflix or
something like that it's about the same
price per month and and so we do the
residential model and then the third is
schools model so we have to recognize
that this is a 30 year challenge and we
need to work with young people who are
first who are the most vulnerable and
make sure from an early age that they're
adopting the right practices and have
the right access and it can be an
incredibly important change agents have
change for families so they go home and
they say well why don't we have a clean
toilet at home
and then from there people to work like
that so then we support our our
operators doesn't matter which way we do
it we help them keep the toilets clean
safe and open and so this ranges from
everything from providing access to
finance if they need it
we work with Kiva which is a micro
lending company online micro lending
company serve Islands if they need it
and then we work with the government to
make sure that that that these guys who
are working in informal settlements
which are often difficult places have
often like nebulous rule of law are able
to keep their toilets open and safe but
as I said this is what people value the
most the waste collection service and so
these guys this is Joseph he is from the
community he's hired as a full-time
employee
he gets health insurance he gets a
benefits he has benefits he gets a
pension he gets inoculations he gets a
uniform and he's able to then take and
he and he does a daily collection this
waste collection is really it's a very
informal profession otherwise and so
this is like a really important
formalization of this and they become
taxpayers which the government likes of
course and and they as and they as as
waste collectors are become it becomes a
dignified job so they take the waste to
the perimeter of the community and then
we have and then we have big trucks that
actually so we aggregate the waste and
then we take in it and then we take the
waste to this this is on the outskirts
of Nairobi about 30 kilometers and here
we've built a waste processing plant
that can take on the waste from about
500,000 people and it's as you can see
that you can't really see the city and
it's very intentional anytime anyone is
even in this country if you build an
organic waste factory waste processing
plant you want to be away from everybody
for the smell perceptions of smell
we're actually next to a leather factory
which smells a lot worse but we still we
still get the grief you know so and then
this is what we do we convert the waste
into two main end products right now one
is organic fertilizer
and so basically this is like a big
mixer that helps break down the waste
and ensures that ensures that there that
that that it's able to then be heated up
which kills pathogens and then we
produce an organic fertilizer that's
helping helping farmers increase their
crop yields by over thirty percent this
is a sort of before and after or it's
against the control of what happens and
and what we're what we're doing is
building the organic fertilizer market
which is which is quite new for Kenya
it's really important to use organic
fertilizers to be able to build out the
the condition of soil as opposed to
synthetic fertilizers which are really
really really established but what they
do is they work on the plant but over
time it ends up depleting the soil of
its nutrients and so this is something
that's really needed to help restore
restore acreage and then this is the
extra cool thing that we do I think is
is that we convert this into animal feed
so these here are they're called black
soldier flies they're maggots and they
eat organic matter so they eat
everything sanitation waste agriculture
waste market waste slaughterhouse waste
it doesn't matter they eat it
and they get really fat and then we
harvest boil and dry them and the end
product is fifty percent protein and
this protein anytime you buy an animal
feed if you run a chicken farm for
example ten to fifteen percent of the
animal feed is an animal-based protein
usually that's fish half of the world's
fish ends up back in animal feed that
then is fed to chickens and cows and
such and so instead though flies I mean
maggots are what free-range chickens eat
so when you're buying your lovely
Vermont chickens or whatnot they are
they're eating you know they're
free-range chickens they are eating just
maggots anyway so this is natural to
their diet and so this has been a way a
way to promote sustainable agriculture
and these chickens and pigs are getting
about thirty
and bigger too and so right now we're
actually in the process with working
with the US government to get a big loan
that actually went through yesterday for
to expand this massively and so thank
you as taxpayers for helping us on that
so let's so this is where we are right
now so you know we started this in 2011
coming out of coming out of graduate
school we serve about 72,000 people on a
on a daily basis with safe sanitation in
one particular slum or two particular
some call mukuru in in the southeast
corner of Nairobi these are all people
who didn't have safe sanitation before
so right there's something that's been
really important then also we're
removing at least 6,000 tons of waste
every year from these communities and we
guarantee all of its treated the
government can't do that guarantee that
nobody can do that so it what you know
the largest safe guarantee provider of
that we've also create a lot of jobs we
have 250 people on staff 65 percent of
these people from the communities that
we serve and then we have all this other
forms of indirect employment to a
thousand operators running these toilets
over a thousand farmers who are
benefiting from the from the end
products and this is this graph is like
the most important thing actually I mean
it's you know it's basically showing
what the difference is with our services
so right now to provide our cert you
know as I said to provide our services
or provide sewers would cost about $56
and the government would be obliged to
pay about 54 of those dollars are so our
model right now only cost about $28 per
person per year to put that in and then
if you take out the fact that we have
these market-based drivers so we have
the operators running the toilets and we
have the waste treatment services it
only cost about 15 dollars to put this
in so it's three times cheaper already
then affordable option or then then the
traditional thinking and at when as this
gets bigger we you know we just recently
did this big study with Ernst and Young
who sent these like Cracker Jack
consultants to help us and and and it
showed that that if we get to five
hundred thousand people this will come
down to about $4 per person per year as
what what's needed for the and that's so
much you know obviously that's about
twelve times cheaper than where we are
with with a with sewers and so we think
this is a really the way of the future
and so though and now the big thing that
comes with the success is that were able
to work with government as a as a
trusted partner and so for example at
the end of last in 2016 we co-developed
the National Sanitation policy this year
we launched advocacy tools that that are
that the entire like Nairobi government
is talking about this is one here it's
called a [ __ ] flow diagram it's a very
yes it's very to the point it was
developed by the World Bank as a tool
but basically it maps where all the
waste is going and the cities feel
really good about you know a city feels
really good about the amount of sewer
coverage it has oh you know forty fifty
percent but then you really got to show
them that actually well not all that
waste is being safely treated and you're
actually missing fifty percent too and
you know and I've had these government
ministers who like come in and they're
just like that they didn't know they
didn't realize this like literally even
though and it's just been how important
it is to develop these tools that then
also you can credibly talk to shaking
and now and then it gets even bigger you
know now we're like working with the
whu-oh so like the largest Health
Organization or most influential Health
Organization in the world to develop a
framework for credible regulation of
these areas too which is really
important because what we're offering
its energy is radical in its way
and that's not always a good thing for
government they don't want to be
necessarily seen as like the only one
who did this and so how can we create
ways to make sure that they feel and
they know that what they're doing is is
well supported so this is where we're
and this is where we're headed with
these with this is that we're trying to
a partnership with the government so
that they're the ones who are ultimately
going to take this on and if that
happens we're in a much better position
than an organization like ourselves
which is constantly fundraising from
somewhere else and then also taking and
having to continually do that but if the
government adopts this is a as a policy
and then we become an effective like a
private utility it'll be really exciting
and so that's what we're and so that's
like the big goal of what we're doing
right now and we're about to make like
some serious progress on that you I mean
I mean one thing that's exciting is like
even this week like things are happening
where where the government is is wanting
to work with us to be able to get big
support from the French government um to
be able to expand their work but then
that's not it for us like we're like
we're not in this for just to serve
Nairobi you know and it's there's over a
thousand cities that are facing the
exact same challenges right like those
images that I showed you at the
beginning of cities that are growing
fast their resource restrained they
don't have as much money as I'd like to
have and they're already extremely built
up already and so what we're trying to
do is is build this whole movement so
that we can serve cities everywhere and
you know and and I'm seven years into
this but it's also I feel like I'm very
much at the beginning too and and it's a
really exciting different new time and
so with that I just yeah that's what I
wanted to share all that with you and
and I would just love your questions as
we build these cities of tomorrow so
thank you
[Applause]
yes please yeah so so well so the way
that the loan works is that you can go
on to the Kiva website oh that we're
taking on oh yeah yeah okay so yeah so
so there's very little commercial
lending that is done with sanitation
infrastructure other than I mean sorry
there's a lot that it happens with
sewers but there's very little that's
done for anything else yeah and so and
so basically what we have to do is is
demonstrate initially how you can you
know is it what structures could
possibly work and so the first one that
sticks are gonna happen for us is that
or it's likely to happen is that work it
were we just got to prove to get support
from the Canadian government where
they're gonna issue a loan to us for
this building out of Sanitation work and
we pay that back based on revenues
generated based on the number of
operators who join the network and from
that we're actually able to be able to
fully service loans on that way as that
as we start to prove that out other as
we start to prove that out but we're we
expect to see other lenders come into
the space for that the big thing though
for us is that this first that that
price has to get down about the cost to
deliver that service and if we can get
that down then it becomes much more
plausible for for governments to be able
to be willing to finance that
it's they're denominated in Canadian
dollars actually yeah so yeah yeah yeah
so what we go to great pains to do is to
differentiate it from synthetic
fertilizer because it's a different
product I mean it's it serves a
different purpose right it's this the
organic fertilizer is serving the soil
and the synthetic fertilizer serves the
the plant and that's like and and then
there but unfortunately they're both
called fertilizer and so and it puts us
in this situation where where we really
need to keep it different so the price
of synthetic fertilizer varies sometimes
it's more expensive sometimes extremely
constricted by the government and so
there's there's issues that come up with
that and we're able to offer this
constant product that just consistently
comes in a little bit lower in cost but
again we really push the farmers to buy
both which makes it a hard sell
sometimes as you can imagine as these
farmers often have to then dip in twice
into their pocket twice but the sales
are going pretty well and the way that
we do the sale mostly now is through a
reseller model so we get other farmers
to sell to their neighbors and building
it in that way and we found like a lot
of success from that the price doesn't
really matter it's all about just buying
from who you trust is the one thing that
we've learned
yeah
so actually so gets a little more
complicated than that so-so no no no no
no I I glossed over it but so there's
actually there's two companies and so
one company is a nonprofit that focuses
on the sanitation delivery and so while
some revenue comes from that there is a
magnificent or there is philanthropy
covers part of that and our goal is to
get that to no longer be philanthropy
through government
the second part the second company is a
for-profit company that just does reuse
of waste into the useful end products
and so that part of the company over
time will become profitable plus yes
plus plus investment capital that comes
in to to build out the the work
ya know yeah it's a good question yeah
sure so so so two ways earth so one the
way the toilets are designed it's manat
a suet connection so most of your heavy
metal content comes from from when
industrial waste is being put into sewer
systems so we barely have any presence
of heavy metals at all however that's
still not good enough and so what we've
done is built a lab so we actually
partnered with the University of
California Berkeley Cornell University
the University kwazulu-natal in South
Africa whoo-hoo we've built a lab with
to be able to test for the content and
so we actually have a better lab than
what's available from like the national
rate and the national regulators in
Kenya and so it's a and so that's that's
how we make sure that we're make sure
the product is safe so so just naturally
our waste takes to waste takes two years
to break down just if you're like
composting it yourself but uh but with
our MIT with our with our the work that
we did the way that just like managing
it with a lot more turning and and and
safely managing it takes it's about five
to six months but with scaling there's
processes out there that you can do this
in much like much much more advanced
level you can do it in like three weeks
they can also so in South Texas there's
there's there's a company that converts
the waste into what's called Dillo dirt
and they sell it at Home Depot and it's
for your flower gardens and such and
they can do that process in about three
days but they're they're much much
bigger than us and so yeah
sure not this one this one yeah
yeah I mean so the bit so so the way so
the government does not pay us yet and
it is a very real concern that I think
that that that I think a lot of us
people who share I mean so the way that
we're managing it is getting the right
advice so you know and getting the right
allies so on the advice side on our
board we have the head of a head of a
utility in South Africa who has been
through these negotiations before as
well as some of the larger private waste
management companies one called Suez and
in that's European so getting that
advice and then also I mean you just
have to you just have to build the
relationships with the with with the
entire government to make sure that they
to make sure that they're on board and
so for example last month I was in
Stockholm with Nairobi count with like
17 people from the Nairobi County
government and really making sure that
we are working with the people who are
the bosses of the ones who would be
administering it and that's you know and
that's the way that you have to we've
learned is like how you sort of can like
force things to happen
yeah ya know and and and it's I mean
it's a ferris right
I mean it's but you know but we believe
that you have like there's sort of a
larger philosophy here like if we're
still if we're stuck on Philanthropy in
perpetuity
are we really gonna you know are we
really solving it and so we you know we
have to have that sort of stubbornness
to be able to say okay government like
we need to work out a way for you to be
able to guarantee that yeah well that
yeah so it's engine you know that's
always gonna be there but I do think you
know III do think that all right I do
think that as you as we're able to show
that this can be done more and more
cheaply it is more and more attractive
you know it's like that's like why
wouldn't we be able to pay for this
whereas when it's really expensive it
gets much it becomes a bigger challenge
yeah yeah yeah no it's I mean but even
here I mean we have a lot of private
utilities or private companies that are
being contracted out by the government
to do this and so where we ultimately I
think Paul is that this is a public good
you know this is something that needs
that the government has an obligation to
provide to everybody in some way the
private sector can play this role of
doing it more affordably to be able to
reach those clients customers
yeah yeah yeah so so so the 56 comes
from modeling done for if you were to
then implement this in the non Seward
areas of the car at the time yeah and so
basically it was like starting from from
a blank slate however like the challenge
with these with like the big sewer
systems is I mean it is it is much more
expensive than that you know it's just
but to build MNT maintain like typically
like that so that $56 number is is a
baked in cost of the capital expenditure
and build it and then to maintain it and
then it's like annualized over over 20
years you make sense yeah and yeah and
so and so it is cheaper but but the
thing is that one we've grown very
accustomed to the sewerage systems and
so introducing
a different approach is something that's
very it's very hard to imagine initially
as as a viable alternative and so that's
where you know that's where it becomes
more of an issue for it for us to
persuade people that this is what makes
sense like the cost can make sense but
everyone's like well still like we
expect what a water based sewer system
to be what comes in and that's what
we're trying to change the mindsets on
more than anything it's interesting last
year I spoke at Hampshire College and at
the admissions office there or the
student injuries they've put in
waterless toilets with composting
toilets you know and sure that's rural
rural Massachusetts but like it is
interesting that there are like ways
that this is starting to happen that
you're starting to see here is like from
a environmentally conscious angle about
about not being not wasting the precious
water we do have so I do think that's
where there's a big change coming where
ideas like ours will be embraced more
yeah
as you see the expansion do you see
maintaining all of these customers as
your your goal in like other cities you
mean or ya know we are our ideas I mean
our our philosophy on expansion is like
meet cities where they are right and if
cities are very comfortable that maybe
you know cities like for example like
Accra Ghana has built like they've
already built like massive waste
treatment centers but they can't get the
waste to it they need someone who can
come in and help them with logistics of
like how do you actually get waste there
and we think that we can we can do that
we've developed sufficient expertise on
that that being said like from an
expansion perspective like no I don't
really want us to be the ones who have
to manage a network of ten thousand
toilets and you know in each city like
that's you know you so what we will
really want to do is how do we create a
replicable playbook for this and one
thing that I spent my time over the last
couple years doing is we've actually
formed the membership Alliance
organization so it's like six
organizations or so about to be seven
that are doing work in Ghana Madagascar
Haiti India places like that that are
taking on the same approach and and do
that we're actually creating like a
standardized industry and as that starts
to happen
you know like repla imeem that
replication is much more much more it
becomes much more readily happening and
then also what's also interesting is
that as soon as you form a membership
Association like all of these other big
players like the World Bank and the
World Health Organization get really
excited and that because not just like
you as like a loan a loan actor and and
that's actually been really helpful for
expanded legitimacy in the sector
you've got it off the ground they used
to successfully have 250 direct
employees so it's wondering what advice
you had for people who are interested in
how do you how do you go from an idea to
what you do yeah so we so we so we were
we started as as students and so and
being a student was like the best thing
you can do if you want to start a social
venture for a variety of reasons one you
have more time than you think you do and
so and so you can go travel like we went
there three times over two years for
about ten weeks so from from Boston to
to tonight Roby to universities like
Yale are extremely well endowed and and
so you're able to you know really do a
lot of research like that we played the
student card a lot when we got to
Nairobi so you would meet like companies
that would probably receive us now as
competition and we were just like we're
writing a paper and and we were we got
credit and everything and and we shared
the paper and like it was you know but
it like really really helped people want
to help students out and you get a lot
of information and then there's a lot
you know and then we were fortunate we
spent our time like entering business
plan competitions and things like that
and and we're able to raise money to be
able to make a go of it for real we
raised over $300,000 in so that that
gave us a good starting point but that's
you know that's just a start and then
once you get there you know and then
what we decided very consciously was to
move to Kenya I see a lot of social
ventures that people are trying to
launch them from from here and you know
and it works for a bit but but but the
real reason I think it ends up not
working as well often or usually is
because you know yeah you have to keep
your ear to the ground you have to be
learning you have to be experiencing how
the people that you want to serve
are experiencing your products services
and and if you're not listening you're
not able to in like you adaptive adapt
to what you're hearing there it's very
hard to make a real go of it and so you
know our operations are in our our
operations are still very much in the
informal settlements and very close to
our customers go yes yeah ah nice yes I
had a
[Music]
but again having lived in Iowa we
understand very fundamental like
institutional yeah yeah I mean thanks
for your question there's there's a lot
to unpack there um so you know I think
the biggest the biggest roadblocks well
as you know and there things can be a
little unpredictable so so like this
past month
I'll just one small example there's been
demolitions in the city and so we had
like all these government approvals
government apologize to us but then they
had to knock down 150 toilets that we
had or we took them back in advance so
we can put them up when they do come you
know there's there they're like
especially like something like the
informal settlements there's so many
factors that come at play like different
so many different ministries that could
have influence on what's happening and
so how do you actually navigate all of
that and the way you know that was a
setback but but you know the way that we
have mitigated that is that we have a
10-person government relations team and
they are at like most like town halls
like you know what technical working
groups are called things like that and
you really have to put that time in to
be able to build the trust and also to
so you can get tips tip offs and just
knowledge about what's about to happen
so you know so I would say that the that
that unpredictability does make things
harder for us you know otherwise I mean
I think you know were were like I'm
pretty optimistic that we're gonna be
able to make that grow
I sort of glossed over this in the
presenting of it but we did genuinely
start initially with just an
entrepreneurial model of just commercial
entrepreneurs running them and we
realized pretty quickly well not well
basically you hit a point like these
entrepreneurs were making money they
were making about a thousand dollars per
year and profit running to toilet so I
can make $2,000
it's about Kenya's GDP per capita they
were doing pretty well and you know and
this was just one of their several
hustles that they might have had going
on so we and so and so but then we
plateaued like because and it was like a
question of space and it turns out not
everyone wants to be a toilet
entrepreneur which is strange to me but
whatever in LA and and then and then
also realize okay can we get these
toilets closer to where people are
living you know and that's where this
landlord model came out of was that like
okay is there a way that we can actually
sell to these people who are who are
controlling their land who are
controlling their land and and we also
know how to have reliable amounts of
money and involved a switching to a
leasing model instead of selling the
asset and so that kind of you know and
so those kind of evolutions have to
happen and so there will be other things
that are gonna happen as we grow to get
to the 500 thousand and it just again
comes back to like us having our ear on
the ground and like making sure that
like you know and being able to be
honest and have the humility of like
knowing when things aren't working what
you have to do to change that
we're in that Ruby do you live raka okay
nice huh okay good cool
yeah I mean I think so this happened so
this already happens in a lot of cities
like this is just a question of how much
you're willing to invest right like in
Boston we have Deer Island and they
process the waste there and it ends and
then they're able and it gets resold
Washington DC spent like two billion
dollars on a technology from Norway to
do this
so like the reuse is there like those
those technologies are there and they're
affordable and I think they're really
important and this world of like I mean
it's sort of hard to imagine a world
where we don't have flush toilets but
like I mean what I mean the scarcity of
water is real you know and and I mean
they talk about wars that are coming
right I and I don't think people are
being too dramatic about that and so we
have to like think like what you know
what can we do to like solve this and
then there are I mean there's plenty of
experience you know there's plenty of
toilet designs even out there that are
starting to actually like to be
waterless and and I think that you you
know and I think that that's just gonna
become more and more natural and I think
that you as users like you probably
won't care like as long as you don't see
where it goes just very practically and
and and that time is coming so yeah yeah
not doing industrial waste yeah and so
[Music]
yeah the waste ring might be easier -
yeah yeah yeah yeah the other piece is
coming from a public health and
nutrition background I'm actually very
interested in you should have a couple
of pictures of your processing I'm
really interested in the stages that
you're using uh-huh and how you know the
digester you're certainly drawing it in
the what step process yeah sure sure no
no no no no no everything's fair game so
so first of all so on your question
about other waste streams so we actually
so people say what we do is too
complicated so I try to simplify and
then of course I leave bits out that we
do do also so we have like so we have so
we have a whole new business line that's
called City it's called City fresh that
we launched about three months ago and
what it does is it collects organic
waste from around the city and so in
developing emerging markets organic
waste is about at least sixty percent on
average of the trash much more so and
much more so than than here and so we're
trying to work out ways that we can be
able to do that so we take on AG waste
for example we work with like one
company that is like they aggregate all
of the bananas that are then sent for
export but then when it gets exported
there's a lot of a lot of different
standards in place and so they end up
having to throw away about ten tons of
bananas every week and so that's what we
feed our flies on partly also so similar
so we do that we do we're working with
malls or working with just last week I
was at the airport for the Kenya Airways
food terminal and as it were and and
they have six tons of waste every day so
like we're working out ways that we can
more effectively and collect that
we haven't got to the industrial wastes
yet that's that's that's that's in the
works but and then and then there's
other companies out there there's a
company called mr. green Africa who and
they're doing all the plastics
collecting - and creating the reseller
market they just signed a big
partnership actually with Unilever
yesterday and so you know and so they're
getting and so and so that that is
really happening and we're trying to
like take do take that on and we think
it makes sense for expansion - because
as you say it serves more needs of the
city than just the sanitation side on
the on the on the Technic on the how we
do the processing okay so so so it's two
separate processes that that happens
with the with the maggots and with the
fertilizer
they're currently done in parallel
they're about to be done in series as we
grow up but the in parallel so the waste
comes in and then we put it through that
mixer to get - turn it up - turn it and
get it really loose and then we put in
wind rows where we do additional
churning and that's basically a three to
six month process for that and at the
end of that you have a safe usable
fertiliser separately what we do is the
is the is that we have the colony of
flies and so it's just in a different
part and so they are the maggots and we
feed them on and we actually used the
technology that's similar to the
mushrooming industry which is also for
industrial mushrooms are grown in
compost so we actually just borrowed
from that and so and so the waste goes
or so then the maggots eat the waste and
then we raise them that way but what's
about to happen is that the maggots
actually leave a residue that can go
into into the fertilizer production and
so we're about to be able to do that in
series so have so much waste basically
taking the maggots the residue from that
and that goes into fertilizer process so
it's very similar to what you have here
like vermicompost thing where you have
where you put worms in the soil in order
to enrich it so it's like very much the
same principle of that yeah sure
yes hmm sure yeah sure so so the reason
that we have to so first of all on the
with the nonprofit no one's ever worked
out how to sustainably serve people in
low-income communities with sanitation
on so it's the same basis and so what we
do is I mean as as much as I present it
as as as a very advanced it's actually
quite new and so we use philanthropic
capital to be able to test out these
these service delivery models and
philanthropy it's it's it's it's
matching like with like like a lot of
the foundations that we work with really
want to be to be working with low-income
populations and making sure that they're
gaining access to basic services the
for-profit is like obviously it's
building a big factory and that's very
attractive to investors right and I mean
there's agriculture input mark is is
well known and so there's you know there
is potential to be able to make to make
a profit from that and so what we did
was when you know we we went out and we
again match like with like and the
investors were like well this is
something this is what's interesting to
us and if we were to put in the whole
sanitation side that doesn't work as a
business model and so we basically put a
line in the sand about where what the
two entities would do yeah
well I mean so we I mean so III mean
that we basically yeah this is the the
for profit is registered as a c-corp and
the the nonprofit's registered is a
501c3 and then we we frame the holistic
idea as a social enterprise so yeah yeah
yeah yeah sure so on the corruption side
I mean you know so you like I mean it's
one of those things where you just have
to assert from a very early stage
what kind of company you're gonna be you
know we've been in like pretty lousy
situations where we're you know you just
like I mean we have one potential client
right now for a waste collection who
they're like yeah if you if you give me
a kickback I will you know I will I'll
make sure you get the contract and
that's actually I mean technically
that's not even illegal you're just like
working with a private company it's
nothing to the government or anything
like that and and but we're just like no
we can't do that and that really starts
with like I mean one the ethics of the
the founders of the company but then
also your government relations person
and the tone that he said and he's like
left plenty of jobs because he felt like
he was being too he was being forced
into extorted situations and such and so
you know he really sets the tone for the
company and in the government you know
has responded accordingly I think that
you know I think that
what we've tried to do is I mean we you
have to be strategically you know you
have to like build relationships with
more than one person like you can't put
yourself in a situation where one person
is going to be totally depending on it
will stymie your progress and has that
and so we've been very careful about
that and making sure that we have lots
of allies and lots of high places and
things like that it is a messy situation
though in Kenya it really is and you
just read the newspaper and there's been
increasing transparency on some of the
corruption that's come out and my
outrage among the citizenry is huge but
still people feel very very bound by
trapped by it - or helpless I guess is
probably the way on attitudes I mean ya
know I mean like I think that like the
way that we measure this is like whether
people continue to use the toilets you
know and making sure that these are
products and services that people want
and that's what's so nice about having a
mark having market-based elements to it
it's like a market tells you something
you know and if these toilets were
something that people didn't want to use
they wouldn't they wouldn't use it you
know they can think of other ways and so
you know and so from that perspective
like where we you know we see I mean
people really appreciate it and it's
interesting in the communities we serve
because previously they just had those
pits that I showed you at the beginning
or they had community toilets which
they'd have to walk long distances to
access and we they never really had
another step to imagine other than water
based sanitation and what we've been
able to show is a step that's sort of I
mean it is as good as in quality but
it's something that's suddenly
accessible to them and we see that
people really respond to that and they
really like that
ya know I mean I think I mean I think
they do
right yeah I I genuinely think they do I
mean I think like the waste is
disappearing you know and it's and it's
a safe private experience and if you ask
people to really articulate what they
want it's not the experience of flushing
the toilet it's it's actually making
sure that the waste away so yeah yeah so
our so our company is 250 people now and
my co-founders so there's three of us
actually another was I went to Yale with
me and graduated in 2003 also but
otherwise we have it's 99 percent Kenya
nurse our team including senior
management - yep
mm-hmm and it's really important you
know in terms of contextual knowledge
and the type of company you're trying to
build I mean like and I talked about
Alex our government relations person
director like I don't go to those
meetings anymore because I don't help
you know and when you look at it can
hurt definitely it can hurt because you
know people don't think and they're
probably right that I understand all the
context of what's happening I often say
the wrong thing shockingly um you know
and they you know it's like just
especially within protocol of how you
talk to government officials and so I
can come in as like a very effective
like you know this is a great thing that
we've built but like Alex always he
always talks about like and then the
next meeting happens where the real
things happen you know and like it said
it's like it's maybe just trying to keep
his job but like ya know
well I think they think that we have a
lot more money often it's like the
assumption is a and like you know
whether it's true or not like what we're
trying to promote is a way that's
actually gonna be about you know about
getting the government to adopt that and
so we would play the strategy
accordingly so those have been
predominantly grant funded so school is
so philanthropy and and the reason that
we actually engaged in the in the
school's program is that it was actually
a good way just to build initial trust
and partnership with government because
because government's bound to provide
sanitation in schools and the
administrative education handles that
and it's actually quite discreet and as
a result we were able to like build that
and now are helping to write the
national standard Asian style policies
and implement yes yeah we do I mean it's
hard we do a fair amount but we have
prioritized what's happening on the
ground more than anything like because
like I mean there's a like there's like
like I'll share something it's like this
isn't gonna sound very provocative to
you all but it's like in the public in
the in the in the academia world of wash
it's like a big deal which is that like
our toilets are shared right so people
use them so if in like you know five
five or 10 families I'll share that and
according to some studies that means
that that that those are extremely risky
toilets but the reason but but but
they've applied a causality to saying
because they were shared that must be
why there's disease and I don't think
that's the case right you can have
plenty of shared toilets that are safe
right when you all drive on the highway
you know here they you should there's
those are shared toilets and you know
people don't get sick right and you and
so you know and so we've had to like
work to be able to change the dialogue
about like it's actually about safely
managing the waste and making sure that
like you know doesn't matter who's using
it that those toilets then stay clean
and if we had just engaged with with the
current where like with the would the
wash school of thought on that like we
would never have got off the ground and
now there's been this these big changes
that are happening where the actual
language around what a better round wash
is actually changing to be able to say
it like the Millennium Development Goal
said access to a toilet the sustainable
development goals have switched to
safely manage waste and like that's only
starting to happen
it's not because of us but we're
definitely one part of that of like
changing people's thinking that you can
actually do this the way that the way
that the you can do this in safe ways
too and so my advice are like I guess
for you know is like you know pay
attention to it understand that you're
gonna have criticisms and critiques that
come from that but but getting these but
getting the work off the ground is can
start to shake things up in other ways
too oh cool yeah
we provide hand washing yeah yeah every
toilet has a hand washing station Purell
no well so what so actually you so it's
sort of funny but so we so that as part
of the franchise agreement they have to
provide soap and water they used to
provide bars or soap but they would
always get stolen and so now what
happens is that people use they take a
bottle like this they take a liquid soap
they cut this off and they put a little
bit of water in it and then they put a
soap in it that way and so that no one
can steal it because the it's like an
open bottle and so that's that's the
most predominant one that's been used so
people get practical quick so yeah yeah
your child's and tribulations but I feel
like the difference that I felt between
India and country yeah yeah yeah yeah
when were you in India just okay cool
okay welcome back yes um so yeah so no
it's so in India obviously they'd so so
it's been really exciting there's this
campaign called swatch bharat' which the
new or not new he's not new now the
Prime Minister that was his number one
thing was sanitation for everybody
and the initial stigma was on getting
people to use the toilet and they didn't
even think through the system side so
then I got they they basically increased
the number of people using sanitation
facilities by 300 million people and
like three years is incredible
but then they still didn't work out
where the waste goes and so now and so
now we're actually getting a lot of
calls from India saying like hey guys
can you help us on it and then and and
and it's really important about like
when you said government policy about
putting in systems thinking on that
we're very interested in this in India
obviously it's you know for a variety I
mean there's the need is so great and so
but and maybe a little too dance
question like starting in the hardest
place is not always the best thing to do
and you know get there you can get there
and like Nairobi like as you know people
like that was a key initial insight for
us was that people were paying to use
those terrible pits like so well then
they'll definitely pay for a better
toilet if it's at the same price you
know and now was something I really was
really important for us as we started
you know and if we get it right in
Nairobi we're in a much better position
to take this to India and succeed there
and so you know you know it's still
really tough but but yeah but like it
was it was a good decision by us on that
no not yet no we have a new expansion
arm that we're working on though at all
there's interest there yeah so so
actually the so-so you know so we really
spent most of our time and if I was
giving this talk even six months ago I
wouldn't say this but like we were so we
were saturate just saturating there will
be like that's operationally that's like
all we want to focus on however there is
so much interest in what we're doing now
and we're working out you know initially
I think we had thought about expansion
is like let's just we do the full
replication and now we're sort of like
actually like let's let's meet cities
where they are you know and so some some
cities want advice some cities want they
want us to assist on a project that's
already starting and so that's what
we're beginning to do and there's a lot
of cities that where the government is
much more progressive has has got much
further than I Roby so like Lusaka in
Zambia for example is it's quite is
quite advanced ours in Dar es Salaam in
Tanzania also and so there's like a lots
of places where where we're starting to
be able to get involved
yeah yeah well we so right now none of
our co-op none of our expansion ideas go
to where other people are that we know
it's been very focused on sort of fresh
cities in that way and that's been
intentional okay it's been mostly
intentional because like it has promoted
a lot more collaboration among the
Alliance when you don't feel like you're
stepping on each other's toes yet and
like we have the presence of mind to
recognize the the the infancy the of our
movement you know and so instead of just
moving directly where we are in
competing over very small pie let's get
this pie really really big and then and
then go that way
i-i-i don't think so not at this stage i
think at this stage we would really step
on each other's toes really really
quickly so yeah cool any other questions
well I'll be here so thank you so much
for coming and it was the most question
I ever got
[Applause]
[Music]